BREAKING NEWS TO COVER
TONIGHT.
STARTING DOWN THE STREET AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE MAN WHO BECAME FAMOUS
FOR SAYING YOU'RE FIRED IS
FACING WHAT COULD BE THE
MOST SERIOUS AND
CONSEQUENTIAL PERSONNEL
DECISION OF HIS LIFE
TONIGHT.
BOTH SUPPORTERS AND
DETRACTORS OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP ARE NOW OPENLY TALKING
ABOUT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN IF
THE PRESIDENT DECIDES TO
PULL THE PLUG ON THE
INVESTIGATION BEING
CONDUCTED BY SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER.
THE TALK ON CAPITOL HILL
COMES AS THE PRESIDENT
LASHES OUT ABOUT A MONDAY
RAID DIRECTED AT HIS
LONG-TIME PERSONAL ATTORNEY.
ALL OF THIS, OF COURSE, AS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES ALSO PREPARES TO
DECIDE ABOUT POSSIBLE U.S.
MILITARY ACTION AGAINST
SYRIA FOR CHEMICAL ATTACKS
THERE.
ANOTHER BUSY NEWS NIGHT HERE
ON "SPECIAL REPORT."
WE BEGIN ON THE NORTH LAWN
WITH CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS.
STEVE AND JOHN?
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING TO
YOU.
THE RAID ON THE PRESIDENT'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY MICHAEL
COHEN'S TWO OFFICES, HIS
RESIDENCE AND HIS TEMPORARY
HOTEL ROOM REPRESENTS A
STEEP ESCALATION TO THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION BY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
ONE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
TAKEN AS A PERSONAL AFFRONT
AND LEFT UNCERTAIN WHAT HE
PLANS TO DO NEXT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
EVERYBODY.
>> ASKED AGAIN WHETHER
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD ANY
THOUGHTS OR INTENTIONS ABOUT
FIRING ROBERT MUELLER FOR
THE FIRST TIME TODAY THE
PRESS SECRETARY DID NOT
ISSUE A DENIAL.
>> YOU SAID SEVERAL TIMES
FROM THE PODIUM THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS NEEDED THE
ATTENTION NOR IS THINKING
ABOUT FIRING ROBERT MUELLER.
DOES THAT REMAIN THE CASE
TODAY?
>> THE QUESTION WAS ASKED
THIS QUESTION DIRECTLY LAST
NIGHT AND I WOULD REFER YOU
BACK TO HIS COMMENTS.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
LAST NIGHT WAS SHARPLY
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT HE HAS
SAID IN THE PAST WHEN HE HAS
INSISTED THAT HE WAS NOT
GOING TO FIRE MUELLER.
>> WHY DON'T I JUST FIRE
MUELLER?
>> WHY DON'T YOU FIRE THE
GUY?
>> I THINK IT'S A DISGRACE
WHAT'S GOING ON.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> SOURCES CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT BELIEF THEY DON'T
BELIEVE HE WILL FIRE
MUELLER.
SENATE JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN
CHUCK GRASSLEY SAID IT WOULD
BE A TERRIBLE IDEA.
>> IT WOULD BE SUICIDE FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO WANT TO